[Musique]
bah écoutez moi je pense que la cancel
culture c'est un peu comme l'islamo
gauchisme en fait c'est à dire qu'on en
parle mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je n'ai pas eu de phénomène avec qui
pourrait nous faire vivre une sorte de
vague moralisatrice maccarthyste ou nord
américaine
je trouve que ces débats là où ces
polémiques là c'est avant fait à cacher
des débats qui sont beaucoup plus réelle
qui sont beaucoup plus importants
beaucoup plus graves qui sont par
exemple la question des violences faites
aux femmes la question des violences de
genre en général ce sont là les vrais
débats en fait auquel la politique
devrait s'attaquer aujourd'hui la grande
scène culture c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas nouveau finalement c'est à
dire que cette volonté militante de
certains groupes de pression de vouloir
bannir
alors on reprend le terme comme celle
donc effacé annulé en anglais donc ces
groupes militants qui souhaite bannir
censurer des oeuvres culturelles et
leurs auteurs parce que d'après ces
groupes de pression il y aurait une
discrimination faite avec 10 y aurait
des personnes qui seraient offensé par
ces oeuvres là est quelque chose qui a
sûrement toujours existé mais qui est
devenu beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus impactants aujourd'hui notamment à
cause du rôle ou grâce au rôle des
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
c'est une pratique nord-américaine qui
est assez assez connus qui s'attaque en
fait aux groupes qui ont des
comportements problématiques qu'on
appelle dominant mouillées qui peuvent
être source de discrimination et donc
c'est une forme de d'ostracisation donc
qui se pratique aux états unis moi je
n'ai pas le sentiment je n'ai pas du
tout l'impression que ces pratiques là
qui fait l'objet de beaucoup de débats
sur nos chaînes de télévision et sur
d'autres médias soit arrivée en france
ce que je constate en revanche c'est que
ces polémiques là autour de lacan cette
culture serbe celles et ceux qui ont
parfois des comportements problématiques
pour inverser la charge de la preuve est
finalement
dénoncer les antiracistes comme raciste
les femmes qui dénoncent des abus comme
étant des des amatrices de délation et
ainsi de suite
oui nous en sommes pas au niveau de ce
qui se passe aux etats unis
mais justement il faut pas attendre que
ça arrive complètement chez nous aussi
pour se réveiller
je pense que justement beaucoup
d'intellectuels beaucoup d'artistes aux
états unis et même à gauche qui était
vraiment marqué à gauche se sont rendus
compte trop tard du piège qui était
donné par rapport aux ce2 au
progressisme qui voulait bannir et qui
voulait tout censurer et on en arrive à
des cas complètement absurde et même
dramatique aux états unis et c'est
justement ce qu'on ne veut pas qui
arrive aujourd'hui en france et on ne
peut pas nier qu'il y a comme même un
petit peu une volonté d'importer ce
sytème pas qu'en france mais aussi en
europe et dans toutes les sociétés
occidentales
est ce qu'on doit s'excuser est ce qu'on
doit accepter ces discours d offenser de
tout poil ou est ce qu'on doit dire non
un moment donné oui vous pouvez être
offensés il faut qu'il y ait dialogue et
de côté il faut pas qu'ils aient une
imposition d'une seule vérité voilà
quand des groupes de pression par
exemple s'en prennent à des oeuvres 40
ans comme autant en emporte le vent
c'est tout le monde qui est touchée
quand ça s'en prend à certains dessins
animés quand ça s'en prend à certaines
oeuvres littéraires c'est tout c'est
tous les lecteurs c'est tous les
téléspectateurs qui sont finalement un
touché par cette campagne de dénigrement
vous me donnez du temps il n'y a pas
d'exemple en france on peut prendre
simplement le toutes les question de
volonté de déboulonner des statuts qui
ont élu aussi en france il ya des
figures aussi dans le cinéma qui ce
conte qui sont pris pour cible en france
et pas qu'aux états unis au nom de cette
culture
c'est une drôle de concept culture en
fête qui existe en france en fait qui
fait que ce sont les femmes les
féministes les offenses et cambo dit
qu'il paye le prix le plus lourd et non
pas les artistes les hommes
celles et ceux qui occupent des coups de
dés place d'importance dans l'édition
dans le cinéma ou ailleurs en fait voilà
donc ne vous inquiétez pas tant que ça
on est encore loin de là conseils de
culture ce ne sont pas ces gens là qui
seront censurés ce ne sont pas ces gens
là qui vont perdre leur rémunération la
place qu'ils occupent aujourd'hui ce
sont celles et ceux qui dénoncent en
fait ces complicités là c'est ces
personnages-là qui paye le prix le plus
lourd